[Music]
hey guys Jarrod again today we're
talking about your favorite Ocelot
enthusiasts Charlie Malory Archer and
his crew of snarky foul-mouthed spies
Jesus Christ Archer is sustained eight
seasons worth of comedy with the
occasional drastic reboot so what we
form a cartel
how hard could it be so what makes
Archer work
what's its secret sauce how does
watching it feel like a familiar
experience even as the show takes absurd
leaps that would probably kill off any
other show Archer succeeds by inverting
rules characters and narrative tropes of
the spy genre while using sound and
language gags to build a unique arsenal
of humor that explores deeper character
psychology welcome this wisecrack
edition on Archer and as always spoilers
ahead it should be no surprise that
Archer borrows plenty of thematic
elements from James Bond duh and/or
hello
but these gags are more than just a
shallow nod to double-oh-seven Bond
films regularly pits the freewheeling
ticular stud against these stuffy boring
rule makers best exemplified by M to
understand why this is important we have
to look at what was going on in America
during the meteoric rise of the James
Bond series according to sociologist
Thomas Andre this time period was a
crisis of masculinity in which the male
desire for autonomy and independence was
displaced by pressure to sell out for a
desk job with a 401k leaving many a man
feeling like an alienated but conforming
employee of a large corporate
bureaucracy spy feelers emerged as the
perfect form of escapism with the
character of James Bond exemplifying the
ideals of independence agency and
individualism that were otherwise
lacking in the day-to-day life of most
American men bonds characterization as a
chronic rule breaker who relied on his
charisma and sheer guts to succeed made
him the perfect hero for the time
unfortunately the Bond style secret
agent is a complete fiction reportedly
after viewing a James Bond film CIA
officers would ask questions like why
wasn't bond required to prepare an
expense report throughout the series
Archer takes this question and milks the
humor of the unglamorous espionage
bureaucracy for all it's worth
I forgot to spend the balance of my
goddamn flex account employment or
calendar year mindless paperwork
occupies a central role on the show
frequently threatening archers ability
to live his best spy life you turned in
an expense report from Berlin where the
German desk says you've never checked in
the show contrast the fantastical action
sequences with the mundane a ''tis of
office life two amazing comic effect
even when Archer does escape the
bureaucratic ramifications of his
actions it's only because of his boss
mom
Mallory's forgiveness later in the
series when the agency becomes a private
investigation firm Cyril is the only one
eligible for a PI license as a result
Archer has to suffer the indignity of
working for the Figgis agency while a
character like Cyril prospers in the
world of espionage bureaucracy Archer
swashbuckling antics are usually
counterproductive I don't see what could
possibly go wrong
and a quick note on Cyril whereas some
might associate paper pushers like him
with emasculated Stooges Cyril is
instead addicted to sex
hello-hello-hello and hyper-sexualized I
think I'm either spanking Archer is the
ultimate James Bond parody it's all
about machismo exemplifying the
qualities he's best known for and then
taking them to their logical unromantic
conclusion like bond Archer is wild and
untamed using drinking fighting
womanizing cars and guns to affirm his
manliness you want to see who's a big
boy throughout the decades Bond films
have fetishized the latest sexiest car
Aston Martin sponsored 12 of the 24 Bond
movies usually offering promotional
deals to let fanboys live out their
dream of buying a Bond car on the other
hand archers car is a birthday gift from
his mother presented to him as if it's
his super sweet 16 oh my god
adding to the adolescent feel the car
gives Archer and embarrassing erection
oh god he's got an erection the show
mocks the way that bonds hyper
masculinity was and still is used to
sell products like cars and beer to men
who want to embody the same qualities
Dodge Challenger Special Agent Edition
brought to you by Dodge Glen Cooley for
the best of times
archers car may be a marker of his
manliness but it's one that's on loan
from mommy who confiscates it days later
again the supposed masculine power of
Archer is yanked away by his more
powerful mother James Bond is one of
cinema's most famous abductors similarly
Archer is hyper sexual constantly hiring
sex workers you owe us a hundred
thousand bucks
all right sleeping with every office
mate would you please come in this dirty
toilet stall and have sex with me and
propositioning every woman with a
beating pulse and some without could you
close your eyes I I kind of feel like
I'm banging taillights on a country road
of course while bond sexual prowess is
legendary
archers is less than that oh you
finished all right yeah maybe try
walleye which by the way makes one of us
and while bond sex life comes seemingly
without physical consequences
Archer frequently comes down with STDs
and has to pay for abortions I'll pay
for his other health effects of the
Bondi and lifestyle are also taken to a
logical extreme while James Bond is
known to enjoy his liquor
archers substance use is superhuman at
one point he literally chugs germicide
his drinking appears to play at least
some role in him getting these
stereotypically feminine disease of
breast cancer any history of alcoholism
you know I mean I drink socially but I
didn't have breakfast hardly the stuff
of a double O Playboy before Archer
undergoes chemo he has some of his sperm
frozen later on Lauda secretly uses that
sperm to become pregnant and have his
baby without his permission or even his
knowledge for the oblivious Archer even
becoming a father somehow plays out as a
twisted form of emasculation cancer
isn't the only health ramification of
archers secret agent lifestyle
there's also tinnitus a hearing loss
caused by too many damn guns going off
all the time either James Bond is always
wearing ear plugs or his creators
ignored the pesky realities of inner ear
damage at one point Archer and his crew
even solidify tinnitus as the show's pet
cause attending an annual fundraiser for
the American tinnitus Association once
again Archer subverts the bulletproof
James Bondy and fantasy by draging
Archer into the bleakest realities of
his mortal body but is there something
more to archers Hearing Loss
communication scholar Ian DAW thinks so
in his essay Archer a spy parody for the
ears dar use that archers tinnitus is
more than an ongoing gag
it's actually an important aspect of the
show's preoccupation with sound and
language which are both used to generate
laughs and to provide deeper insights
into character psychology to prove this
dog conducted a study in which he
watched every episode of archers third
and fourth seasons and counted the
number of linguistic or sound specific
references including language jokes like
puns foreign language references or loud
gunfire followed by the high-pitched
ringing of archers tinnitus da found
that such references occurred on average
10 times per episode in the third season
and 11 times in the fourth which comes
out to approximately once every two
minutes just as mundane office politics
serve as a humorous contrast to the
life-threatening action sequences the
show's language jokes are often employed
at the most inopportune moments dog
takes special interest in one of the
show's simplest ongoing gags archers
frequent act of calling out loudly to
Lana even when she is nearby is more
than just a simple annoyance it's
reminiscent of a baby calling out for
its mother which for Archer probably
never quite gave him the comfort he
needed I don't feel good essentially
archers increasingly louder appeals to
Lana signal his inability to control his
demand for attention eventually other
characters adopt the same gag Pam what
Pam
what based on the growing frequency of
these appeals for attention Goss says
clearly it is very important in this
show for characters to be heard
however it also seems to be important
that they not be heard too quickly by
the listener bringing up themes of power
demand control and psychological
repression for instance take archers
classic phrasing joke and don't you want
to freshen up after your long ride
raising mother this is a classic use of
what Freud called double entendre in
which the joke depends quite specially
on the sexual meaning even though the
words have an alternative non sexual
meaning Freud thought that these sorts
of jokes were a way to release some of
the nervous energy that comes from
repressing sexual or aggressive desires
that's particularly significant when
archers aiming the joke at his mother
for whom he has more than an inkling of
an oedipal complex no just half of one
but beyond that when Archer says
phrasing he's essentially choosing to
miss communicate and willfully
misinterpreting the speaker's words the
stealing the conversation by choosing to
only hear the sexual innuendo Archer
often ensures that the person won't be
hurt at all
guess I'm a bad listener the tech that
quickly becomes one of archers favorite
ways of hijacking a conversation as
language tends to do phrasing spreads as
the other characters start adopting it
thank you for coming so quickly
in fact the joke eventually becomes so
ubiquitous that it actually circles back
and falls out of fashion like yellow or
on fleek archers anxiety over the
plummeting popularity of his favorite
joke only confirms how important these
attention-grabbing antics are to his
identity the world's image of a perfect
man reduced to a man-child phrasing
isn't the only way to avoid hearing what
a character usually his mother is really
saying take the running gag about
archers voicemail messages which become
increasingly elaborate ruses to trick
his mother into thinking she's actually
speaking to him sterling sterling listen
very as a result Malory has entire
conversations with his pre-recorded
voice before realizing she's been duped
here Archer is taking great pleasure in
the power he's able to wield in a
conversation with his mother
this voice message gag is archers
hilarious
if juvenile means of temporarily
reclaiming some power momentarily
undermining Mallory's dominance over him
just as Archer has trouble bending to
the will of Isis's human resource
department he often finds himself
struggling with the rules of language
learned that flammable and inflammable
mean the same thing
both restraints prevent Archer from
living the badass spy narrative he
envisions for himself one such example
occurs in the three-part series heart of
archness when Archer has declared
himself king of the Pirates he attempts
to address his subjects through his
translator / slave Noah
okay pirates hey hey take a knee that
won't translate it's like last week when
you said lend me your ears and they were
like oh dammit I can't do it 'i'm sorry
shut up Archer attempts to convey his
message without these idioms but quickly
finds it impossible well I never
realized how much we rely on idiom you
win this round here are our church Apes
against the rules of language just like
he chafes against the rules of
bureaucracy but even when he's not
dealing with inconvenient language gaps
Archer still has trouble expressing
himself no I still got that stammer huh
while James Bond is well known for his
pity one-liners Archer is not so gifted
certain left his tail between his legs
frequently regretting his failure to
come up with the perfect witty lines oh
wait I got something for this hush
puppies damn that's better again Archer
parodies bond by turning his funny
offhanded innuendos into a chore in
which Archer still comes up short
commence operation take it back so then
commit suicide
other times archers language isolates
him particularly when he's attempting to
connect with others over his favorite
obscure cultural references I would
prefer not to bartleby the scrivener
anybody not a big Melville crowd here
huh while he's constantly grasping to be
heard and to impress through his brainy
call-outs he rarely receives any
affirmation am i Williams
fire it's always disappointing to have
your thoughtful cultural references fall
flat and not even the greatest spy in
this fictional cartoon land is immune to
the shame
read a book archers chock full of
fantastical fight sequences wildly
ambitious spy missions and unnecessarily
complicated weapons technology but much
of the show's humour rests and the
linguistic communications between the
characters I honestly have no response
to that his lingering adolescent sense
of being an outsider formed over an
impressive 15 years spent at boarding
school are perfectly expressed in his
over enthusiasm for coining group slang
and his wildly obscure pop-culture
references that inevitably fall flat
most of all Archer embodies the
perennial secret Asian struggle born out
of the 1950's masculine anxiety about
being cogs in the corporate machine but
what do you guys think
well sterling Archer ever learn to
listen will there ever be a joke good
enough to replace phrasing yes let us
know in the comments and as always
thanks for watching guys ease
thanks for watching wisecrack if archers
got you itching for more great animated
content get your fix
over at verb that's vrv and if you act
soon you can get 30 days free to check
out all the shows and channels they've
got to offer verb is a mega service that
gives you unlimited access to awesome
channels like curiosity stream drama
fever and anime favorites like
crunchyroll and Funimation where they
recently added dubbed episodes of Dragon
Ball super not only will you be able to
instantly catch great anime like my hero
academia black clover burrito and food
Wars but you'll also be able to watch on
the go without an internet connection if
you think that sounds great Verve wants
to give wisecrack fans 30 days of free
HD ad free viewing for all 13 of their
channels if you sign up before the end
of December when you order for premium
you get everything that includes shudder
where you could get your horror fix with
a bunch of scary series as well as
exclusives like Harmon quest bravest
warriors and bee and puppycat so head
over to Verve Co slash wisecrack or
click the link in the description to get
your 30 free days of Verve premium
before the offer ends this month you can
get it on your desktop on their mobile
app Roku Playstation or Xbox
thanks to Verve for sponsoring this
video and we've got tons of great stuff
on the way including videos on Deadpool
and up so if you haven't already be sure
to subscribe alright catch y'all next
time
peace